[Music]
on this monday night
mega merger the blockbuster deal between
two telecom giants worth billions
the impact on consumers on jobs and why
federal approval is not guaranteed
reassurances and refusals about the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine
friends phoned us and said don't take it
plus a bc city and covet hot spot
opens a rapid mass vaccination clinic
the tough bind of relying
on covid benefits i'm behind on all my
bills calls for
a repayment amnesty plus partying in the
pandemic
it's actually great to see the world
functioning it's enormously
spring break in america millions are on
the move
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a multi-billion dollar
deal that would merge two of the most
powerful business families in canada
rogers communications has agreed to buy
its rival
shaw communications and red flags are
already being raised about what it could
mean
for consumers the transaction is valued
at 26 billion dollars including 6
billion
in debt rogers and shaw carved up canada
when it came to cable and internet
service
rogers operated in the east and shaw in
the west
but they have been fierce combatants in
the wireless sector
now rogers is promising to invest 2.5
billion dollars to build 5g networks in
western canada
plus one billion dollars to give rural
remote and indigenous communities
high-speed internet
it's also promising to create three
thousand jobs in western canada
big money and big promises none of it
will happen
unless the deal gets federal approval
and that will include explaining why
less competition is good for consumers
mike gerlay has our top story tonight
for generations rogers in the east and
shaw in the west played in their own
backyards
while the invisible fence between the
two could soon come down
if telecom regulators approve rogers
buying its western rival
to build out its 5g network this is all
digital and wireless
i mean this is this is the future of the
world right
bell is the undisputed top telecom
company in the country
merging shaw with rogers levels the
playing field while leaving consumers
with one less
cellular option as part of the 26
billion dollar deal
rogers is offering up some promises one
of which is customers of shaw's freedom
mobile
won't see a price hike for three years
but telecom experts agree the math adds
up to one
thing higher prices this is a long game
it's nice to know that your costs may
not be going up for at least a couple of
years
or three years but we know that in the
long term they will
and that absence of competition in many
ways really guarantees
the the notion that costs will go up if
this merger goes through
politically that could create a problem
for prime minister justin trudeau
who promised in the last election to
reduce cellular bills by 25
over two years everyone complains that
they're paying
too much for cell phone service
comparing two gigabyte plans shows
canadians are paying
seventy four dollars on average compared
to sixty dollars in the us
twenty five in the uk and twenty two
dollars in australia
as part of the deal rogers also promised
to create 3 000 new jobs in the west
while maintaining a regional office in
calgary where shaw is based
maybe that'll continue and maybe it
won't the likelihood of the
sophisticated jobs thing in calgary
frankly is low
it's going to shift over time it'll
shift east it almost always does
so if the prices go up and the promise
of jobs doesn't pan out
will the benefits of an operational 5g
network be enough
will mitchell of the rotman school of
business says if you look at the bigger
picture
it has to imagine we don't have
sophisticated 5g
and the us does and china does and korea
does and the rest of the world does
and we're trying to compete on 4g or or
mediocre 5g
we lose the deal is subject to regulator
approval
and won't be finalized until sometime in
2022
mike trolley global news toronto there
is lots to digest in this deal to help
us
break it down more and gaviola our new
senior business correspondent is with us
and welcome
rogers and shaw are framing this deal as
a win-win for
everyone the press release says it will
generate more choice and competition for
businesses as well as realizing the full
benefits of next generation networks for
canadians
and canada's productivity how much of
that and his hype and how much is true
i would take that with a grain of salt i
mean keep in mind that messaging is
coming from the people
trying to get this deal pushed through
every analyst
and industry expert that i've spoken
with says no matter how you slice it
this
looks like basically based on the way
that it's been presented
it's going to equal less competition and
higher prices for
consumers across canada and in addition
to that even though there is a lot being
promised here for western canada in
terms of new
jobs you do have to sort through some of
that corporate speak and buried in there
is the fact that rogers expects to
realize
annual cost savings of about a billion
dollars
in the two years after this deal goes
through
if that does happen and a lot of people
are saying you know that could come in
the form of job cuts maybe not
necessarily in western canada
but in other parts of the country and
this is not a done deal it needs
government approval what's your read on
that right it's going to be an
uphill battle for sure there are still a
lot of stakeholders that need to sign
off on this
if you take a look at what happened to
shock communications shares on the stock
market today
it looks like investors do not believe
that this deal as presented is expected
to pass they've been trading shares of
shock communications
below the rogers offer price and in
addition to that there are several
regulatory hurdles that this needs to
jump over so the crtc is going to be
scrutinizing this
as well as the competition bureau the
ministry of
innovation science and economic
development has to weigh in on all of
this
and this would set an important
precedent as well it would
effectively you know decrease
competition which is
the opposite of what federal policy has
been trying to do here across canada
over the past decade
all right our senior business
correspondent and gaviola in toronto
thanks
achiel burgers were back in the
spotlight today brothers craig and mark
founders of the we charity were
questioned under oath by the house of
commons ethics committee today a process
they describe as
a political trial our michael couture
was watching the hearing mike
what happened well donna it took a
summons from the ethics committee
but the kielberger brothers did answer
questions for over three hours and
they came out swinging with their lawyer
by their side and a scathing opening
statement
the co-founders of the we charity took
swipes at politicians
of all stripes saying the committee was
putting them on trial
in the court of public opinion we didn't
advise the prime minister and mr bono
not to recuse themselves we never probe
parliament
we're not involved in the decision to
filibuster the committee this fall
this is a political scandal for the
government not with charity
but they say it's both the charity and
the kids they help that have suffered as
a result
the 543 million dollar canada student
services grant program was handed
to we charity without the usual
tendering process
but has since been canceled it's
resulted in the ethics commissioner
investigating both former finance
minister bill morneau for his ties to
the charity
and prime minister justin trudeau as a
number of his family members have
appeared at we charity events
have either even contacted by the rcmp
despite being asked several times the
kielberger brothers say they're not
being investigated by the rcmp the
canada revenue agency
and the internal revenue agency in the
u.s
but they are cooperating with a number
of other probes related
to the canada student services grant
some of those probes are looking
at the access we charity had to the
highest levels of government
despite not being registered to lobby he
goes directly
to the finance minister of a g7 country
and calls him by his first name
that is lobbying it's lobbying
they might think they're besties but
it's lobbying i will simply point out
again
that there is literally not legally
possible for me as a volunteer
to register opposition mps also brought
up a thank you message craig kielberger
sent to his senior staffer
inside the prime minister's office
thanking him for his help in shaping the
program a message that kielberger says
was simply a form letter sent out by his
executive assistant
donna mike look at her in ottawa thanks
now to covet 19 and concerns in europe
about the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
france germany italy and spain have
become the latest countries to pause
their use of the astrazeneca vaccine
there have been a small number of
reports in europe of people developing
blood clots
after being vaccinated several of the
world's top medical agencies are
reassuring people saying there is no
clear evidence
the shots caused those blood clots the
european medicines agency says it is now
reviewing the reports and it's urging
countries to
continue their rollouts the astrazeneca
doses
being used in europe are from a
different production facility than the
doses being shipped to canada
prime minister trudeau today tried to
reassure canadians about getting the
vaccine
here but as mike armstrong reports some
lingering doubt
is setting in
touring a mass vaccination center in
montreal the prime minister got
personal for a moment crouching down to
speak to a woman waiting for her
shot he shared that his mother was
vaccinated last week
but one of the big messages on this day
was again about supply
to reassure canadians the astrazeneca
vaccine is safe
and works the best vaccine for you to
take
is the very first one that is offered to
you
that message is being repeated over and
over by politicians
and experts the questions around
astrazeneca's vaccine
don't apply to canada's supply europe's
using a different manufacturer so
they're completely different batches
that isn't getting through to everyone
this woman refused her shot monday
morning once she found out it would be
astrazeneca
the reason our friends phoned us and
said don't take it
those doubts and gossip are having an
impact one local health board in
montreal reports
10 percent of people offered astrazeneca
over the weekend
refused so most of our vaccinations will
happen here for many
the option they're hoping for is a
pharmacy as of next monday
350 montreal pharmacies will be offering
vaccinations
for anyone 65 years and over they're
going to be giving the modern vaccine
the booking is only being done online
but spots are being scooped up quickly
since this morning the phone's been
ringing non-stop for appointments
now quebec's ramping up hasn't come
without hurdles several spots in the
province monday
had patients waiting for appointments
outside in
temperatures below minus 20 degrees
celsius
but the biggest challenge remains supply
hoping it keeps growing
going forward mike armstrong global news
montreal
the retired military general in charge
of ontario's vaccine rollout is leaving
the job
premier doug ford revealed today general
rick hillier will finish
at the end of the month i think i'm
going to put a ball in a chain around
his ankle to keep him i try to get him
to renew it but as he said
doug i did the job i came for and we got
everything set up
and now as i agree with him
ontario though has faced intense
criticism over its slow rollout and
confusing messaging
today the province launched its vaccine
booking system people
80 and up are eligible to sign up though
there were early reports of some
glitches with the system
though ontario's rollout is starting to
pick up so are highly contagious new
variants and that's led to a stark
warning
from the ontario hospital association it
says ontario is now in a third wave and
it says variant cases are
rising steeply it says strong adherence
to public health measures
is urgently needed to prevent
overwhelming hospitals
the campaign to vaccinate an entire city
within weeks
coming up why prince rupert is
accelerating its mass
immunization plan
bc is pushing ahead with its covid19
vaccination campaign people aged 84 and
up can now book appointments
in the northern city of prince rupert
adults of any age can get their shot
the region launched a sweeping
vaccination campaign today the goal is
to get every adult immunized by
april 1st global's ahmad agahi is there
to explain how the city is doing it and
why ahmad well this is an unprecedented
vaccine rollout and people in this
community are excited to be taking part
with the
entire province and country watching
the first vaccinations started at 9 00
am sharp this morning at this
civic center behind me that has been
transformed into a vaccination clinic
and it is here
where the entire adult population in the
town of twelve thousand will be
immunized over the next two and a half
weeks
okay one two three and with that 87 year
old perry boyle becomes the first
eager participant of a community-wide
immunization campaign
the likes of which we have not seen in
canada
it's like anything else even if you got
a job somewhere get
there and get at her
and that's just what i did here this
morning health officials are
targeting the small northwestern bc
community with an accelerated approach
aiming to halt its surging covet 19
infection rate we've done our best as a
community
with very few exceptions to follow all
of dr bonnie henry's recommendations
but there's some really unique
circumstances in rupert
the city is remote its hospital only has
a few acute care beds and
40 percent of the population here is
indigenous citizens that are
disproportionately affected
by the virus in canada then there's the
devastation of the community's long-term
care home acropolis manor
where dozens including understaffed
workers tested positive
and at least 14 residents died if there
was any other community
that had our geography shared our unique
risk factors and circumstances
we would wish them well we would not
accuse them of jumping the queue
or or being rewarded for bad behavior
for 86 year old martha wainwright there
was no hesitation
having to go out shopping maybe feel a
little
safer and while no one knows exactly
what will happen after the health
officials here finish their work
for the first time in more than a year
there is hope on the horizon
definitely people are feeling like
they're going to be able to plan for a
post pandemic spring
versus a late summer or fall that we'd
all been anticipating
the first week of this mass immunization
campaign will target those between the
age of 60
and 95 and then the goal is to have a
shot in the arm of every adult in prince
rupert
by the end of the month and from those
that i've been speaking with
who are involved in this vaccination
effort well they're saying that if
things go smoothly they won't be
surprised if this unprecedented campaign
of vaccinations finishes well ahead of
schedule donna
okay matagahi and prince rupert thanks
prime minister justin
trudeau made an official trip outside
the nation's capital for the first time
in months today he was in montreal where
he announced a major investment
in a factory that makes batteries to
power electric vehicles
both the federal and quebec governments
will invest 50 million dollars to build
an assembly plant north of the city
lion electric the company behind the
project will put up 85 million dollars
the factory will create 135 jobs once
it's complete it's expected to be
operational
in 2023 beijing's air
apocalypse ahead the wild weather
smothering china's capital
this is what it looks like in beijing a
massive sandstorm has shrouded china's
capital in orange dust and smog
residents have been told to wear masks
and avoid outdoor activities
the city's air quality index reached its
maximum level of 500 and hundreds of
flights have been cancelled because of
visibility
sandstorms are nothing new in beijing
they blow in from desert regions near
the city but residents say they haven't
seen one this bad in years
almost a year ago no one had ever heard
of the canada emergency response benefit
the two thousand dollar monthly
assistance program became a lifesaver
for millions of canadians out of work
and out of pocket because of the
pandemic
and since it evolved into the canada
recovery benefit
billions more have been paid out tonight
abigail beeman talks to those who have
relied on it
and who fear what comes next
when live drag shows became impossible
chris reed
aka continental breakfast moved online
it was venues and
nightclubs and theaters that closed
first
and will most likely be the last thing
to come back
and i realized that like all of a sudden
it felt like my job had almost become
illegal
virtual wasn't easy this show was
reported for being explicit and taken
off social media
so reed started their own production
company queer based media
the money isn't nearly as good reid had
to move and relied on first the canada
emergency response benefit
and now the canada recovery benefit
reid's now worried about whether they'll
get a letter from the cra
saying they need to repay some it was
constantly
thinking that i was either making too
much money or not enough money
and i'm behind on all my bills
you know the people who are already
struggling before the pandemic
numbered in the millions of canadians
natalie appleyard says the vulnerable
are hardest hit by coping 19.
she's one of many advocates along with
the ndp calling for a repayment
amnesty rather than try to squeeze money
out of people that
already are struggling to put food on
the table we believe that anyone below
the low income threshold should be
exempt
from having to repay the serb and
that we could just consider this an
investment i'm very
very afraid i have no idea what i'm
going to do
yvonne spicer has relied on federal
benefits for a year
now she's stressed about having to pay
back more than 3 thousand dollars in
provincial disability benefits she
attends college
and is a caregiver for her mother you
don't get a lot to
cover your expenses it
really makes you feel like
if i wasn't living with my mom i
wouldn't have a place
a roof over my head the federal
government was not able to tell us by
deadline how many people were told they
need to repay
benefits the employment minister's
office tells global news they will be
flexible and understanding but the
minister herself has said
an amnesty is not on the table abigail
beamon global news
ottawa next spring break in america and
millions are partying like there's no
pandemic
spring break in canada is underway for
many students in british columbia nova
scotia and prince edward island
but it's not like there is much to do
travel is still discouraged and
our airports are mostly empty
across the border though millions of
americans packed their bags and are
getting ready to party
as jackson proskow reports the pandemic
is still with us but in parts of the u.s
you'd never know it like a scene from
the before
times the party is back on
in the sunny southern u.s spring break
hasn't taken a break
despite the pandemic yeah i just feel
like
it's time to move on with our lives and
stuff and
get back out there it was just a lot
more relaxed down here
a lot less people wearing masks no
surprise big crowds are gathering in the
states with the fewest restrictions
disney's florida theme parks are fully
booked airlines have seen
their busiest days in nearly a year 1.3
million passengers per day
passing through u.s airports it's
actually great to see
the world functioning so normalcy i miss
seeing
people out enjoying themselves the
centers for disease control cautions
the virus hasn't taken a vacation this
is all
in the context of still 50 000 cases per
day
they've asked people not to travel
warning case numbers could quickly surge
again
erasing recent progress i'm feeding with
you for the
sake of our nation's health spring break
hot spots like florida
and texas are where those more
contagious variants are spreading faster
than anywhere else in the u.s
that's the part that concerns
epidemiologists so you have to worry
about people
getting infected with that bringing it
back home where maybe they don't have as
much of an issue with it right now
and potentially creating an issue as the
weather warms up and as
lockdown fatigue sets in caution is
increasingly a tough sell
i wouldn't say we're really concerned
about it right now to be honest i feel
like it's pretty much tamed right now
and so for the first time in a long time
millions of americans will carry on as
though everything is back to normal
even when it's still so clearly not
jackson prosko global news washington
and that's global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's euro
canada
is a frozen balm beach in tiny ontario
yes it's a real place on georgian bay
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye